So in particular, once we've
supplied a set of actions in a state
representation, we would like
agents to do as well as they can,
without necessarily
questioning what we gave them.
So in this case of
temporal abstractions,
again, hierarchical optimality is
the notion that the agent should
do the best that it can,
respecting the high level,
their temporal extract actions that
they're given without having to question
whether it could do better by not
listening to that whole concept.
>> Right and so maybe, it's the case
that we should include in our options,
every single primitive action,
every single atomic action.
Maybe we don't have to do that.
It really just sort of depends upon
what you're trying to accomplish and
what the trade-offs are.
But we're making those
trade-offs all the time,
even when we define
the problem in the first place.
>> I guess that's fair.
>> Right, but in the same way that
once we have all the machinery of
SMDPs in place, we might as well just
pretend that we're dealing with MDPs for
this kind of purposes of planning and
learning.
We sort of should do that
with the set of options
that we have in the set of
state features that we have.
So that's a big win that we're
going to still get optimality.
It'll be limited by the set of
options that we've constructed, but
it was limited by the set of actions
that we had in the first place.
There's other things that
sort of fall out from that.
One, is state abstraction,
which we talked about before,
that because we have these different
options, if we are lucky or
clever we might be able to define
options that don't require that we pay
attention to the entire state and pay
attention to everything that's going on.
And if so, that can be a big win.
But there's also something else and
I said this on the first slide,
because we're able to jump ahead
from one doorway to another doorway,
it allows us to avoid wandering around
in say, this northeast room, right?
Which means, we get to avoid what I'll
call the boring parts of the mark off
decision process.
The parts of the state
space that don't matter.
Because remember, fundamentally,
in order to do reinforcement learning,
we have to worry about
exploration versus exploitation.
But the options, because they
have these policies built in, and
because they're trying to accomplish
very specific things, allow us to
avoid having to pay attention to
large parts of the state space.
So, they actually help
us with exploration.
So, with the idea that we can focus our
decision making energy on the places
where those decisions actually have an
impact, as opposed to stuff that really
there's only one right answer,
we shouldn't be thinking about it.
>> Right, so in fact, the word that you
that you mentioned as a phrase used
there that I think is just perfect,
which is, we need to focus on the places
where we can actually make decisions.
And because options allow us to kind
of jump forward in time, it means,
in some very important sense
from planning at that level,
there are no decisions to happen here.
We made the decision when we
decided to execute the option,
go to the southern door.
How it gets there, is it's business.
We're just assuming that it works.
In the same way, that when we
decided to execute the up action or
the left action,
we didn't worry about what was happening
while that action was being executed.
We didn't think about it at all.
Those are the decision points.
That's what makes
the decision process and
that's where we should be building
our computational energy.
So, insofar as we can jump ahead in the
future, we can avoid making decisions,
which means we avoid doing
exploration and that is a huge win.